as the weather changes and time flies by
it's important to protect your skin from
the environment and from aging we spoke
with chiclavi med spa the sponsors of
this next segment to see how they can
help
at chicla v as soon as you walk in
you're going to be welded with this
beautiful building
but i think that's just part of the
whole experience once you're past all
that and you come in and you see the
talent that we have here and the
technologies that we have here for skin
health for body contouring we can really
make a tangible difference in our
patients skin and in their lives so for
skin care at chic lily we have multiple
options for our patients for skin tone
for skin type for textural imperfections
for discoloration we treat melasma we
treat rosacea
we have a number of technologies
advanced technologies that actually do
make a tangible difference in the skin
the most popular i would say that our
clients love to come in is the
hydrafacial it is a traditional
three-step hydrafacial but we like to
customize it with each person who is on
our table we also offer what's called
oxygeneo which is just making its way
here in the united states it's actually
quite popular in europe and canada it's
canada's number one facial
we offer intraceuticals oxygen infusion
technology that originated in australia
and it is the ultimate hydration which
is so important here in the las vegas
weather with our dryness so when we can
even combine those technologies we can
really customize to our patients needs
we offer
a variety of chemical peels and finally
what i really think makes chic with the
unique is the fact that we offer
microneedling with prp and also the
vampire facial i am a certified vampire
facialist and when we offer prp
into the skin it's a tolerance your body
is not going to react and our results
are even sped up faster so we have
amazing laser technology here at chicle
v i am a medical laser safety officer so
you're in very good hands with myself
and any of our technicians we have
what's called fraxel which is
fractionated technology which really
helps with fine lines and textural
imperfections as well as tone
we offer laser hair removal we have a
gentle max pro which is great for
our fairer skin types and our darker
skin types it has two wavelengths to
accommodate any skin tone that walks in
comfortably safely and effective we also
offer cutera here which is primarily
laser genesis and vascular and we use
that a lot for reducing redness and also
reducing the appearance of scars
our non-laser technologies which are
very advanced would include our venus
viva which is nano needling with radio
frequency we also offer the venus freeze
platform which is radio frequency for
body contouring and toning and tighten
the skin
we offer ipl to take care of acne and
keep your skin opalescent and my
favorite that we offer here is ultherapy
which is the only fda approved device
for lifting and toning and tightening
the neck the decolletage and the lower
face so we have something for everybody
here
[Music]
thank you to chiclavi medspa for
sponsoring this segment give them a call
at 702-233-8535